because afternoon ladies and gentlemen
what an honor and privilege it is to be
with you here especially in your
presence mrs. Galbraith I be in
parentheses feel obliged because of the
reach of this great forum to make a
minor correction of John's introduction
of me I was privileged to win the
National Book Award for an American
Requiem but not for Constantine sword to
be in this space of course especially
for those of us of a certain age is to
remember the question that we all were
shocked to find in our hearts in 1963
and again in 1968 as to whether the very
powerful and precious legacy that we had
all been invited to embrace by the great
figures of the Kennedy brothers John and
Robert whether that legacy would survive
how it would survive how it would be
carried forward we're here this
afternoon of course to celebrate the man
who has been the pillar of that legacy
down through these decades and what an
honor it is to honor him in this way
speaking quite personally I'd also like
to acknowledge the pleasure and
happiness and one could say deep
satisfaction that has been over the
years to discover in my own generation a
few people a handful of people who
carried that legacy on quite worthily
and what a privilege to be on the stage
here with two of them a Robert Rice and
Richard Parker as writers and as men of
powerful political commitment have with
John Kenneth Galbraith embodied so much
that was opened before us by the two
towering figures of John and Robert
Kennedy so I want to begin by
acknowledging my honor and being with
you
and Richard and as a way of introducing
the discussion join my words to
professor Galba race in celebrating this
amazing biography that Richard Parker
has written which is the occasion of our
conversation Whitman said great poets
require great audiences we use the word
great too often we should reserve it
quite specially for a few a handful of
human beings and surely John Kenneth
Galbraith is one of them and in Richard
Parker's work he has a great biographer
the great question of our time is
whether intelligence and commitment and
compassion worthy to the problems we
face are with us in abundance
Richard Parker has identified
intelligence compassion and commitment
in full abundance in the life of John
Kenneth Galbraith he's put it on display
for us to remember it and to reclaim it
but in a very powerful way richard has
also and maybe this is his great service
reminded us of what Galbreath basic
message has been all along which is that
compassion intelligence and commitment
are available in abundance in the
American people and in the democratic
idea and that affirmation comes ringing
through on every page of the work that
richard has given us so it's a pleasure
to begin our conversation by inviting
Richard Parker to respond to professor
Galbraith and to put on the table before
us the points that he think that he
thinks that we should have most in mind
as we gather today to honor Ken
Galbreath
Richard first of all thank you
and what a pleasure it is here to be
with Bob rush as well and with all of
you I first of all I'm so sorry that
professor Galbraith couldn't be here
today he hoped to up until the very last
minute but his health at 96 is not what
he would like it to be but as you can
see he remains mentally alert
I took a reporter up to see him a few
weeks ago and about 15 minutes into the
interview
galbart slowed down precipitously and I
thought this is a sign of something
serious until I realized that Galbraith
had noticed that the 35 year old
reporter couldn't write fast enough to
keep up with him at 96 so he remains
quite vital and with us in in a number
of ways this has been as my wife who's
with us today understands an enormous
piece of my life for the last eight
years we have two small children and
much of the writing was done between
4:30 and 7:30 in the morning and there
were honestly several points at which I
thought I wouldn't be able to complete
this book but I have and what kept me
going was always the sense that men like
Ken Galbraith had preceded me and that
in a sense morally as well as a run as
as a writer I had an obligation to him
to complete the telling of his story
he's a man who was born in 1908 when
Theodore Roosevelt was president he's
lived obviously through two world wars
in the Vietnam War he served four great
American presidents Franklin Roosevelt
Harry Truman John F Kennedy Lyndon
Johnson he still admired today by
President Clinton who as Clinton left
office wrote professor Galbraith
proposing that the two men write
together a book on the future of
American government and only because of
professor Galvez health
did he decline to do this what is it
about
galbart that attracts men like those
presidents to a farm boy whose first
eight years of education were in a
one-room schoolhouse and whose initial
college education at Ontario agriculture
college caused him to remark many years
later that he had attended perhaps the
worst school in the english-speaking
language which of course set off the
Alumni administration of OAC
by terribly and caused Galbraith in his
own distinctive style to recant when he
told Time magazine that perhaps he'd
been wrong to say what he had
undoubtedly Arkansaw a and M was a worse
college but he hadn't been sure they
spoke English at Arkansas am but
Galbraith has I think that we have lost
sight of is the value of strong
commitment he tells the tale of being a
young boy and his father who was as tall
as Ken is was a was a major leader in
southern rural Ontario of the Canadian
Liberal Party and Ken was taken out as a
boy by his father shortly after World
War one to see what political
campaigning was all about they went to a
neighbor's barnyard and there were a
dozen or so farmers gathered to hear
Archie Galbraith talk about the
candidates who were to be voted on than
the following week an Archie surveying
his audience spotted a large manure pile
in the middle of the barnyard
immediately strode over to it and
stomped on to the top of it and sinking
down into it began his speech by
apologizing for speaking from the Tauri
platform
Galvis said it taught him both the value
of conviction and the uses of humor he
wasn't sure that it changed many votes
but it sees he's stuck with his father's
style ever since so I think that again
what struck me about Ken Galbraith first
of all was the extraordinary conviction
that he brought with him the humor and
then most importantly the consistency
like Bob I was trained in a kind of
neoclassical economics that when I was
an undergraduate and graduate student
led me to think as many of my colleagues
did that Galbraith was an interesting
figure but fundamentally not to be
reckoned as a major force in modern
economics economics had gone far beyond
the kinds of things that Galbraith did
and although john maynard keynes
reasoned in the same non mathematical
ways that Galbraith did and eschewed the
arcane mathematical modeling that
Galbraith did that somehow by the 1960s
his style of economic reasoning had gone
out of fashion but about 1990 or so when
I took up this book I looked around the
profession and I realized that it was a
profession in crisis the American
economics Association itself had
conducted a survey of its members and
asked among other questions do you
believe that we have become over math
Matus eyes and two unrelated to the real
world and two-thirds of those surveyed
agreed with the question there's a
crisis in American intellectual life
that is a crisis in American liberal
life and American political life in
American cultural life all simultaneous
one with the other and the Galbraith for
me offers at least a window into a way
of existing and working in the world
which overcomes those crises and in a
sense offers us not if not a perfect
model at least an exemplar and a model
of what we should in our own generation
in our
'we become what i valued always about
him was not only his commitment to
reasoning about economics in english
trying to identify not the most
difficult mathematical problem to solve
but the most important problem of the
generation but it was also a commitment
to doing economics in a way that
understood that it was most fully a
political project because economics was
in some sense politics being carried out
through numbers and finally that he
understood that economics needed to be
presented to be to the public in a in a
manner that allowed the public to
directly participate in the most
important decisions over their economic
and political lives simultaneously only
by doing political economy not by doing
the recondite mathematical economics of
this 50s 60s and 70s could all of those
goals be achieved now was Galbraith
always right in his predictions no as
mathematical economics done better in
its methodology it's not at all clear to
me that it has and the cost of being
esoteric the cost of being over
abstracted has been very painful across
the planet as powerful nations and
powerful intellectuals have used poor
and oftentimes very vulnerable human
beings as guinea pigs for their planned
economic models and reforms Galbraith
always had a sense that the subjects of
economic reasoning were the objects of
economic reasoning were human subjects
like himself and it seems to me today
that that compassion is Jim speaks of it
is at the core of the right way to think
about economics and a new century and
why we owe so much to Ken Galbraith
there's a second dimension
Ken's life which is his firm commitment
not merely to be a blackboard professor
he could have been had the opportunity
to be but chose not to be always chose
to live in the world testing his ideas
against the experiences that he found
there and trying then to reconcile the
world he discovered with the world that
he and his colleagues debated in the
seminar rooms and taught in the
classrooms I don't think that you can
understand Ken's view of economics
without understanding what he learned as
a young New Deal aid in the 1930s when
in the middle of the Depression farm
price supports were created in the New
Deal administration and were put in
place for wheat farmers and corn farmers
and were working very well but as Ken
started his career in the New Deal the
question of cotton arose and the
question was who would receive the
payments the handful of powerful white
men who owned the plantations where the
black and white men and women who picked
and tended and carted the cotton and one
of galvers colleagues a young lawyer
from the triple-a was called up to the
Congress and was taken into the office
of Senator cotton Edie Smith of South
Carolina cotton ed was the chairman of
the Agriculture Committee and happened
also to be a cotton plantation owner
himself and he summarized the role of
power in economic decision-making in a
brief but compelling way that gal was
never forgot he told the young lawyer
you take care of the payments will take
care of the [ __ ] gal burrs lesson was
that power was always present in the
significant economic decisions that we
make in our lives and that there are
beneficiaries and there are victims and
there can be bystanders but morally
someone's such
himself could not be among the last in
the Kennedy administration I was struck
reading the correspondence that he and
President Kennedy carried on over the
two or three years of Kennedy's
administration includes not only the
letter that John Shattuck read to you
that was so prescient given that it was
written in 1961 before any significant
American treatment the commitment had
been made but includes dozens of other
letters in which he counseled President
Kennedy wisely courageously repeatedly
to stay out of Vietnam not only because
it would be a foreign policy disaster
but because it would be a domestic
disaster a domestic economic disaster
because it would set off inflation just
as he had seen inflation start to
explode in the Second World War and had
been brought under control only by his
own work at the office of Price
Administration and it would prove a
disaster politically for the Democratic
Party for liberalism and for liberal
Keynesianism and to read those letters
today is to realize how much has been
lost and yet how right in his wisdom ken
Galbraith was about what was at stake to
watch him then work over the remaining
40 years in which he has continued to
write and lecture and carry on what I
consider a singular moral campaign about
the highest values that the American
people represent is to introduce all of
us to what it means to be courageous and
consistent throughout one's life it was
a privilege for me to work with
Professor Galbraith it was an education
for me to interview him and the men and
women who were so important in his life
and I hope for you who take the time to
read this book or those of you who
certainly I hope have read professors
Galbraith Messer Galbraith many books
that you can draw again in this shaded
dark for many of his time the light that
his intelligence and his moral clarity
his wisdom bring to the great issues
that are still before us thank you
first of all let me add my thanks to
John Shattuck for setting up this
program and to Jim James Carroll for
being here also my thanks to my old
friend of 40 years a Richard Parker for
40 years for writing this extraordinary
book and Kitty my love to you and please
extend it to Ken as well I'm so glad
you're here with us there is so much to
say and and really such a limited amount
of time to say it I want to say just a
couple of things first of all to add to
what Richard has said Ken Galbraith to
me represents an old and superior
intellectual tradition and that
tradition is about not only political
economy but moral philosophy Adam Smith
did not ever call himself an economist
Adam Smith called himself a moral
philosopher in fact before 1890 when
Alfred Marshall the great economist
wrote his principles of economics there
was not really a separate discipline
called economics it was all part of
moral and political philosophy and it
would have seemed unthinkable for
writers in the 18th or even most of the
19th century who were writing in effect
about economics to separate economics
from politics and from a view of what a
just society is all about so Ken go
brave like Thorstein Veblen in the early
years of the 19th century like to some
extent john maynard keynes but certainly
like those moral and political
philosophers of the eighteenth
nineteenth century understood the
relationships between economics politics
and the good society in a way that is as
important if not more important today
for people to understand than it ever
was before
we are as we sit here we as a nation
making economic decisions
that have enormous moral and political
repercussions and we're making political
decisions that have enormous economic
and moral consequences for this country
and unless those are seen in context
we're going to make some terrible errors
which we are doing we figuratively
speaking not anybody I hang around with
I spend my time at Harvard and Brandeis
and Berkeley and everybody everybody I
speak with agrees with me in 1958 I had
my first my first contact with Ken Bob
Wright who became very quickly something
of a hero to me and let me read them to
you the passage from the affluent
society in 1958 that just struck me I
was only two years old at the time but
it struck me anyway this is about
private opulence and public squalor you
may remember this it's a passage in
which John Kenneth Galbraith talks about
the family which takes its mold and
serese--
air conditioned power steered and power
braked automobile out for a tour and
passes through cities that are badly
paved made hideous by litter blighted
buildings and posts for wires that
should long since have been put
underground before going on to picnic on
exquisitely packaged food from a
portable icebox by a polluted stream and
spending the night at a park which is a
menace to hop public health and morals
well it could have been written today
about today Ken Galbreath understood
something not only about the
relationship between politics economics
and morals but also about the public
sector and the private sector that
public investments in the environment in
public health in public safety are no
less important in fact in many ways more
important than private investments in
factories and equipment that a good
society not only has a balance
but a good Society makes sure that the
markets and the large corporation does
not tip that balance too strongly in
favor of the private side lest we all
suffer less the common good suffer
common good public interest remember we
used to use these terms Ken Galbraith
was read and revered in the 1950s and
1960s and 1970s at a time in our life
our life together when public leaders
not only used him utilized him referred
to him but also made decisions that
often not always not nearly enough
reflected the kinds of values and
principles that can incorporate a
brought to bear now I don't have to tell
you what's happened since then but I do
want to say something about leadership
leadership is the art of getting the
public to pay attention to something
that it often doesn't want to pay
attention to leadership takes guts
public leadership is the hardest of all
when the Kennedys and before them
FDR paid attention and got the public to
pay attention to what it needs to pay
attention to they did not rely on polls
you can't lead the public to where it
already is because it's already there
that's what polls tell you you can't
educate the public about what it doesn't
want to be educated if you are catering
and pandering to a public that is
already has certain preconceptions ken
Galbreath
opened our minds he was a public
intellectual he affected our public life
and it was not always easy in the 1950s
he was accused of being a communist
in fact sinclair week's Secretary of
Commerce made sure that J Edgar Hoover
did an investigation on John Kenneth
Galbraith I don't know whether you know
about this investigation but there was
an FBI investigation here's what they
turned up
I looked it up in Richards book the
report there Hoover report came back on
the target of the investigation that is
John can call break was found to be okay
except quote conceited egotistical its
snobbish apparently not grounds for
further investigation
in 1971 Ken Galvez testified before
Congress in favor of wage and price
controls at a time when wage and price
controls might mean fighting inflation
without drafting into the inflation
fight those who are at least able to
bear that burden and those who are
drafted first into the inflation fight
as we do it now are the poor there's the
first ones to lose their jobs when we
use unemployment as a vehicle to fight
inflation
well wage and price controls said Glenn
Galbreath in 1971 might be a way to deal
with this problem without putting such a
burden on the poor instantly Richard
Nixon denounced ken Galbreath they went
to his staff and said do an
investigation try to smear this man I
learned this from Richard's book as well
but interestingly three weeks later
three weeks after that Richard Nixon
announced that he was instituting wage
and price control which prompted Ken go
breath to say he felt like the
streetwalker
who had just learned that the profession
was not only legal but the highest form
of municipal service
ken brought Galbreath allah brought wits
to his wisdom and one thing he also
taught us and we will talk much more
about this is that a spoonful of sugar
in the form of little humor helps a lot
of medicine go down
thank you so Robert you mentioned the
affluent society it's as a writer that
Ken Galbraith has made his greatest
public contribution over the recent
decades what one or two books should
this audience and the people watching on
television read of Ken gall brace this
month what what good day which pick pick
out a couple of one that I have one that
I find particularly relevant and I hope
it doesn't become relevant this month
but it was certainly relevant in the
year 2000 is uh actually a king over its
most popular book bestseller it's called
the Great Crash many of you have read it
it's about what happened to this country
in 1929 but I please I can't resist go
because you have to think about what
happened in the year 2000 2001 think
about people like and I hope I'm not
committing libel but Ken Lay maybe Tom
DeLay you hear the connection to the
economy this is from the great crowd to
the economist embezzlement is the most
interesting of crimes alone among the
various forms of larceny it has a time
parameter weeks months or years may
elapsed between the commission of the
crime and its discovery this is a period
incidentally when the embezzler has his
gain and the man who has been embezzled
oddly enough feels no loss there is a
net increase in psychic wealth at any
given time there exists an inventory of
undiscovered embezzlement in or more
precisely not in the country's
businesses
banks this inventory perhaps it should
be called the bezel varies in size and
the business cycle in good times people
are relaxed trusting and money is
plentiful but even though money is
plentiful there are always many people
who need more under these circumstances
the rate of embezzlement grows the rate
of discovery falls off and the bezel
increases rapidly and depression all
this is reversed audits are penetrating
a meticulous commercial morality is
enormous ly improved the bezel shrinks
so I would say James the great crash
would be my nominee for understanding at
least the first half of this decade what
would you suggest Richard I'd say
probably the affluent society in
American capitalism is two places to
start affluent society because it's
there that he introduces this idea of
the social imbalance between the public
and the private sectors he has he has
told how in the middle of the 1950's he
set out to write a book called why
people were poor that was meant to look
at the issue of poverty in general until
it became absolutely clear to him that
America the 1950s had entered a new
stage in human history which was that we
were a society in which now only a
minority were poor and that the terms of
economics in such a society were quite
different from the terms that might
apply to an economics to a society in
which scarcity was the governing rule
his point was that now with affluence
there was no longer a concern about
scarcity for the majority at least when
it came to private goods that's the
great passage about the movin surive
Surrey's automobiles the SUVs I guess of
the 1950s but he said at the same time
the politics of the nation had starved
the public sector for the schools and
the good roads and
the healthcare systems that worked for
all and in trying to get to that social
balance lay the future of politics and
economics alike and again like so much
of what ken has written it seems to me
so extraordinarily pertinent to today
one of the researches that I did about
before the book included looking at the
amount of money that had been spent on
the military in the United States the
one part of the public sector that has
never really been underfunded then
Brookings in 1995 calculated that since
the end of the Second World War
in 1995 dollar terms the United States
the United States had spent 21 trillion
dollars on its military seven trillion
of which it had spent alone on nuclear
weapons 7 trillion dollars on nuclear
weapons and of course something like
another three trillion have been added
in the last 10 years to that total
military spending and it was there that
Ken saw the the kernel of a kind of
insanity in public sector spending that
was what needed to be addressed and so I
recommend the affluent society first I
thought of another book that Richard I'm
not sure you everything is in your book
but I did not find a reference to this
book and that may be there and it's a
little book that is as relevant today
for at least part of the population as
anything else that Ken Galbreath has
written and it's called who needs the
Democrats and what it takes to be needed
it runs about 80 pages and every page is
as relevant today was written I think in
1967 67 and probably as relevant today
as it was in 67 and in 67 the Democrats
were a little bit more relevant
Rober I can't believe I said that Robert
elaborate the point what what would it
take for the Democratic Party to more
fully embody the tradition that
Galbreath stands for was famous for
saying at graduation commencement
addresses the most important thing for
undergraduates or graduate studio went
out in the world was to learn the
importance of comforting the afflicted
and afflicting the comfortable and I
think that that's pretty much summarizes
what a Democratic Party should stand for
not class warfare but simply the
realization that at least right now we
have the widest disparity in wealth and
income and opportunity arguably we've
had in this country in over a hundred
years and that there is only one group
that is doing astoundingly will people
in the top one percent they've never had
as much wealth they've ever had never
had as much income I'm in danger of
being called a class warrior but I'm
going to say it anyway if we do not
expect people who are richer than ever
to pay at least something toward the
possibility that everybody else can get
ahead and have a good life we cannot
have a coherent society and that's what
Ken Galbreath would write if he were
writing that book right now we're going
to invite members of the audience to
join the conversation in a moment but
before doing so I'd like to ask you both
to turn your attention a bit to another
major contribution at least in my view
of Professor gall brace and I'm thinking
of his consistent skepticism about the
use of military force and in a
particular way what his early experience
was close up of strategic bombing in
World War two and what that meant to him
over the decades would you give us a
summary of that experience of his and
his positions Richard surely in the
closing months of the Second World War
Ken was made a director of the strategic
bombing survey a group a commission that
had been established by the Pentagon in
the White House to investigate success
US strategic bombing of Germany in Japan
like so many Washington Commission's the
conclusion desired was already known the
conclusion that was meant to come out of
the commission was that strategic
bombing had been overwhelmingly
successful and that that success
justified the creation of an independent
United States Air Force as many of you
may remember in the Second World War we
were the only major power in which the
Air Force was still part of the army and
the airmen wanted desperately to be free
of the ground soldiers with their own
Air Force when Galbraith and his
economists got to Germany and began
digging through the records of the Third
Reich in interviewing people like Albert
Speer they discovered that unlike the
confor our dein conclusion that was
being sought German military production
had increased not decreased throughout
the Second World War
at the end of 1944 the Germans were
producing more fighter planes more
bombers more tanks more artillery more
arms than they had been in 1941 in short
the strategic bombing had not crippled
the Germans capacity to undertake war it
and in fact encouraged them to
ingeniously to disperse that production
and increase that capacity and Galbraith
decided quite amazingly that this was
the truth and ought to be recorded as
such and this of course produced a
harrowing set of weeks in which he and
George ball fought for this conclusion
it was reluctantly accepted by the
people directing the survey and placed
in the survey but in a secondary section
of the report and a Pentagon press
conference was called to announce the
conclusions of the report but before a
week before that happened Galbraith was
immediately dispatched to Tokyo to
investigate the situation in Japan and
so with Galbraith out of the country the
Pentagon called the press conference
overlooked
the section of the report which said
strategic bombing had failed and
announced that strategic bombing had
been an overwhelming success the press
dutifully reported it and soon
thereafter an independent United States
Air Force was created an Air Force that
I should add has continued to practice
the the merits of the the the strategy
of strategic bombing in Korea Vietnam
the Balkans and most recently in Iraq in
large part to no greater success than
they did in the Second World War and
Richards book makes it very clear that
ken Galbraith was no dove that is he
certainly understood the importance of
the use of force strategically but the
use of force without diplomacy made
absolutely no sense when he was
ambassador to India and he saw the just
the beginning stirrings of the United
States involvement in Vietnam he warned
against it very clearly he wrote to the
president and Richard helped me with
this because my memory from your book is
that there was some discussion with the
State Department as to whether an
ambassador could write the president
directly and the Secretary of State
asked that hair from here at that point
on that Ken Galbreath as an ambassador
to India not send any telegrams to the
White House but always go through the
State Department which invited Ken gall
brace response a memorable response
which because I don't remember exactly
the words I'm going to defer to Richard
it probably does remember that I
remember them he wrote to President
Kennedy that tried to communicate
through the State Department fornicating
through a mattress
thank you for that Richard that excuse
me mrs. Galbraith ladies and gentlemen
you're welcome to join the conversation
there's a microphone here and the
microphone there and I'll recognize you
sir thank you to the tomes that you've
recommended talk about events the great
crash afterwards society new industrial
state this is about the man himself it's
a 1981 memoir called a life in our times
there's a laugh on every page
sometimes at his expense the gentleman
is recommending professor Galbraith own
memoir of 1981 a life in our times
yes sir there's been a lot spoken here
today about continuing this legacy of
Galbraith and Kennedy and I'm just
wondering what you foresee for the next
5 10 15 years and also what can be done
to continue this legacy in these times I
know I've read reason professor Reich
and you give lots of great
recommendations there and I know
professor Parker you talk about not
thinking so much in 4-year presidential
cycles but thinking in 20-year political
cycles I'm just wondering what needs to
happen on the part of concerned citizens
to uphold this legacy well I would say
the most important thing is for
concerned citizens not to turn cynical
but to get more involved than ever
in the wake of the past two elections I
come across a lot of people who say look
I I tried so hard I've never worked so
hard in my entire life and I'm just sick
of it and I'm afraid nothing is going to
work and that kind of attitude it seems
to be as the most dangerous because that
seeds the ground and concedes democracy
to the other side and frankly I don't
think the other side is all that much
interested in the kind of democracy we
have right now I am frankly worried that
for example the wall between church and
state is being systematically dismantled
there could be
people have got to get involved there's
no substitute for direct involvement
politics is not something to hold your
nose over politics is the applied form
of democracy and I say that to everybody
in this room most of whom have been
involved before but you've got to stay
involved other particular institutions
you think that are doing a good job now
that are worthy of supporting like
moveon.org or things like that well I
think there are many good organizations
and you can find them on the Internet
The American Prospect the lil magazine
that I have found but it's more than
sending money and I think that a lot of
people confuse donating money with
actually being politically active
one of the great casualties of our time
is that people can so easily feel that
they are fulfilling their social
conscience by just writing a check it
takes more than that it takes actually
the hard work of grassroots politics and
it also takes people in you know states
like this blue states calling up friends
and relatives in so-called red states
and talking to them respectfully but
entering into a dialogue with them we
don't we're not talking enough with each
other in this country about what's
important can I just add on to that one
of those interesting things about the
book truth I'm currently on is the
number of right-wing talk shows that
have been interested in talking to me
about Galbraith they're not obviously
putting me on in order to spread the
Galbraith ian's message but they want to
engage the Galbraith ian's message
because they find contemporary liberal
politics to be so anemic what they find
attractive about ken Galbraith is that
he was a vertebrate liberal and I think
we need to get back to encouraging
vertebrate liberalism and by that I
would suggest to you that a lot of these
interviewers start by asking about
whether or not
Galbraith Ian liberalism has gone out of
date and after all aren't we in a new
period of fiscal responsibility in
limited
and it is impossible to allow those
republican frame those republican frames
of argument to stand you need to simply
stop the conversation and say to them
but you must understand under george w
bush the United States government is
larger than it was under Lyndon Johnson
larger than it was under John F Kennedy
larger than under Harry Truman and
larger under than under Franklin
Roosevelt during the Depression the only
time in American history that American
government has been larger was under
Franklin Roosevelt in the Second World
War
what is this Republican Party of limited
government at the other and at risk of
just uh overstating that point it's very
important that followers of Ken gall
brains books and philosophy Ken
Galbreath who argued for a Keynesianism
that was a responsible Keynesianism that
called for public spending on schools
and on health care and on parks and
Environment to understand that we have
since the early 1980s embarked on
another very different Keynesian
experiment we might call it military
Keynesianism this is something that in
the Cold War we didn't do very much
until 1980 and that military
Keynesianism has to some extent in a
very limited way kept the economy going
but it has not helped much of the public
lead better lives over here yes ma'am I
just finished reading a book called
confessions of an economic hitman by a
fellow named John Perkins and he
describes his role in what he calls
America's economic imperialism
that rather than invading countries and
taking them over by force before Iraq I
guess we were subjugating them and he
took describes his personal role in that
by economic means by giving them so much
money and lending that they and can
never repay and therefore we own them so
it's been a kind of way of taking over
countries by subjecting them to
unreasonable debt
what did John Galbraith what were his
thoughts on role economically in the
world in that way Galbraith was drawn to
the problem of global development quite
early in fact he began in the early
1950s to teach the very first course
that Harvard ever offered on
international development he extended
his practical knowledge in the 1950s
through his work in India and then of
course continued on his Indian
ambassador in the 1960s you'll find
Galbraith as early as the late 1950s
emphasizing the role of education
particularly the role of the education
of women the central the central need to
provide for some sufficient domestic
production of agricultural Goods so that
poor populations are not subject to the
whims of global agricultural markets and
finally encouraging domestic development
of industrial and urban sectors rather
than relying on the importation of vast
amount vast amounts of first world
capital in order to follow a Western
development model so I think Galbraith
been quite consistent on this oh now you
can find him in the 80s and 90s
consistently criticizing the behavior of
the World Bank and the IMF under
strategic adjustment terms there's no
the record there is spotless one of the
one of the best books coming out of the
Indian experience for Ken Galbraith was
called the culture of mass poverty which
I think opened a lot of people's eyes to
not only have the International economy
the international trade international
direct investment may inadvertently
maintain mass poverty but also what many
countries need to do for themselves
before coming to you sir I'd like to
make just an
servation I think one of the keys to
understanding this man's power is to see
his national and international reach in
the context of a profound commitment to
a locality to this place actually to
Boston Cambridge you you this is of
course symbolized powerfully not only by
his major and adult lifelong commitment
to Harvard University in its community
even as he was marginal to the tradition
of academic appointment his powerful
commitment to the Kennedy a political a
tradition that is so alive in this state
his faithful support of Senator Kennedy
and when congressman Kennedy in
Massachusetts was in office and
congressman Kennedy and Rhode Island a
proud clear affirmation but also how
many books did a Ken publish well
forty-eight actually there forty-two
published by Houghton Mifflin but
they're half a dozen more now you have
to remember those sold eight million
copies and he didn't write his first
book on his own until he was 44 first so
for those of you still welling about
becoming a writer it goes to my point 42
of his books published by the Boston
publisher Houghton Mifflin company I'm
sure that Kenneth Kenneth John Kenneth
Galbraith understood the empower of that
Boston tradition this is the week in
which the Atlantic Monthly announced its
move to Washington professor Galbraith a
major contributor over the decades to
the Atlantic Monthly this Boston
tradition was precious to him is
precious to him and it's important to
you know claim him as someone who whose
greatness is in part because of the
great soil that he sank his roots so
deeply Israel yes sir my name is Michael
Giovanna mission and Serbian
in Dostoyevsky's novel Brothers
Karamazov two characters engaged in
conversation and one told the other it
is always very useful to to hear
intelligent men we have to quote
Dostoyevsky's character today in
listening to your gentlemen that is very
useful to listen to intelligent men
not only us but the leaders of our
government would have liked but we to be
useful to hear what you said tonight
unfortunately as many of us who know our
government now is much worse situation
than ever was since America began
tonight there is going to be documentary
that rules that in Churchill wanted
World War two to take place they wanted
it they told us the tonight'll had to
listen to it at nine o'clock you know
that the Second World War started when
Adams Hitler wanted to join dancing
which gets 400,000 Germans and 1600
pause they said no to that church she
did not want anything to do with Hitler
at the end of the war Hitler was dead
but 15 millions of human beings died
nowadays excuse me sir I appreciate very
much your invoking this important piece
of history that professor Galbraith was
present for would you conclude with a
comment or a question and then I'll ask
my my question is going to be led to
this short comment if you did not
intervene it would be shorter
I welcome the shortness incidentally I
like very much for true right but
today's remark that's another subject
okay go ahead Saddam Hussein wanted to
join Kuwait because at one time that was
one country during Ottoman Empire
we told them who have nothing to do with
that and then when he entered again we
invaded Iraq and the whole cold hell
broke out now I can actually that this
is my question all three of you you
don't wanna say what is better for the
world peace at any price or victory at
any price what is better for the world
peace at any price or victory at any
price who's that the question well
actually either of you might jump off
from that to reflect on Professor gall
brace well you know I think I think
particularly sitting here at the Kennedy
Library because I sat upstairs in the
research library of this building for so
many weeks in so many months and was so
touched to handle documents from the
Kennedy administration of course one of
them is professor Galbraith draft for
President Kennedy's 1961 inaugural
address as you probably know besides Ted
Sorensen and the President himself
professor Galbraith was one of those
asked by the President to prepare a
draft for that inaugural and the line
that I most remember from Ken's draft
that survives in that inaugural of john
f kennedy's cuz we must never negotiate
out of fear but we must never fear to
negotiate
what this country has got to learn is
how to strike a balance between the
export of fear and its willingness to
negotiate as much with its allies as
with its enemies that's how it answer
your question thank you
and over here
no doubt analysis of what happened in
the last election will go on for decades
a little closer to the microphone please
is that better what I said did you hear
the first part no study no doubt what
happened in the last election will be
analyzed for decades to come
how did the Bush gang get in and I it's
I can't imagine that professor goal
breath with his student which did not
comment on this to some of you a
particularly you mr. Carter and the more
we understand about how they did that
the I mean a lot of people feel that
this is the beginnings of a fascist
takeover and there's a lot of
resemblance to what went on in Germany
in the 30s I guess it you know maybe
that's stretching it a little but I'm
not so sure did did professor Goldberg
saying anything about this in his own
express any of his own thinking about
this to you because the more we
understand it the more I think we will
be prepared to try to do something about
it either one of you I can tell you what
he told me on the phone the day after
George Bush was reelected which is that
I called him up and I said so Ken what
do you think there was a pause at the
end of the line and then rumbled the
voice across those lines Richard I never
thought I'd long for the Reagan
administration
I don't think he in any way sees us is
on the verge of a fascist America this
is a man who survived Harding Coolidge
Hoover Eisenhower Nixon Reagan George
the bush senior and George W so he
thinks that both the Republic and even
he will survive for some time into the
future I think that what we need to
remember is that in some sense it's what
Bob has been saying earlier and what Ken
has always said which is that we must
not lose sight of our determination to
keep on working for the values and
beliefs that matter the moment that I
most enjoy was recounting is that in the
early 1970s some of you may remember
there was a global food crisis and the
Soviets started buying grain from the
United States secretly from the Nixon
administration and there was talk of
food problems around the world and one
theory was that meteorology was to blame
this thing called the El Nino had
something to do with it and perhaps
global warming and the like and some
young reporter went to Professor
Galbraith and was asked and and asked
him do you think that climate has
something to do with the global food
shortage they pulled himself up looked
down at the young reporter and said
young man never blamed the deity for
anything as long as Richard Nixon is in
the White House
I think we need to keep Ken Galva sense
of humor pointed humor alive today if
things are going wrong we have plenty of
people to blame and we know what their
first and last names are but I don't
think we need to fear for fascism in the
future let me let me if I may let me add
to that one of the truly great aspects
of this book that Richard Parker has
written is its intellectual history of
the 20th century not just a biography of
Ken Galbraith but because Ken Corey's
life is so intertwined with the history
of ideas and politics in the 20th
century at least from the 30s on it's
very much of an intellectual history of
the 20th century and one thing that we
can see emanating and it emanates from
the book is an optimism an optimism
about the forces of reform in this
country now it is true that beginning in
1968 and certainly after Watergate the
public's confidence in governments began
to decline indeed one could argue that
Vietnam was the beginning Vietnam then
Watergate the Iran gate and so forth and
if you ask people in 1960 do you believe
that government does basically most of
the time would it should do for the
public interest most people said yes a
majority in 1960 said yes and then that
majority steadily declined until there
is a minority of around the last time I
looked around 32 percent who will agree
with the statement most of the time what
is in the public's interest well it's
very difficult to sell the concepts of
the affluent society that we need a
vigorous public sector when the public
is so distrustful and yet and yet there
is as something that can Galbreath is
pointed to a fundamental asymmetry
between the administration's of those
people who don't believe in government
and the administration's of those people
who do and that asymmetry is that when
you don't believe in government and you
screw up you are advancing your cause
yes sir
Jack Porter from Newton I have a
question I said as I get older I keep
dusting off some of these books that I
read in the 60s and you mentioned
intellectual history and I'm very
curious what his relationship with was
with intellectuals like Searight Mills
on his left and a a Burley on his right
what was the relationship of Galbraith
in the 50s and 60s to these men and some
of his contemporaries a very curious he
wasn't acquainted with Mills he
certainly had read burly's work in the
1930s but I was not I mean he
encountered Burley a few times in the
30s 40s and 50s the thing that always
struck me was how much Ken Galbraith was
creation of Ken Galbraith the the
intellectual figure that was most
powerful in his life without doubt with
John Maynard Keynes and the other I
think most influential man in his life
was his father
Archie canes because Keynes as Keynes
did for Ken's generation finally
provided a theoretical structure that
could both save capitalism and tame
capitalism
I had an Oxford tutor I don't Bob had
the same tutor Tommy Balog a famous
English laborer right Keynesian and he
always loved to tell the story of
sitting at high table years ago when a
Don in French he asked him why is it
that you economists always are at war
with one another so vehemently and he
said well you must understand that
economics is much like modern religion
he said try to imagine Adam Smith as
Abraham the founder of the try
Alfred Marshall as Moses the lawgiver
but John Maynard Keynes as Jesus Christ
who had come to both save and redeem but
transformed the law and that that moment
that Keynes brought into Ken's
generation transformed that entire
generation of economists and the figures
that you mentioned Burley and Mills
while significant as individual thinkers
were always footnotes for the Keynesian
the Keynesian zuv Ken's generation this
man probably a very quick question but
in light of what you said about
Professor galbrace failure of the
strategic bombing and you know sort of
as Oppenheimer said his first rocket hit
London you know great success but wrong
planet but what were proposed regards
thoughts of when the u.s. bombed
Hiroshima and not Cassini at NACA sake
what did he think of the use of the
American use of that force and how did
that his relationship with JFK during
the Cuban Missile Crisis direct how does
its thinking and does that any of that
he was appalled by the last high he was
appalled by her Oshima as a member of
the strategic bombing survey in Japan
and as for the use of strategic bombing
in the Kennedy I'm not quite sure what
the second part of the question was
about the Kennedy what were his
conclusions after whatever relationship
he had to the Missile Crisis
what were his conclusions about the
threat of nuclear war
his conclusions after the Cuban Missile
Crisis were no different than President
Kennedy's we now understand which was
that within 60 days after the Cuban
Missile Crisis Kennedy began in secret
the preparation of the speech that
became the famous American University
address on containing the nuclear arms
race that both men had stared at death
and seeing that it was death for the
planet as a whole and that it was
madness to continue down this road and
that's I mean it's the important that
you read that speech in light of
Kennedy's experience of the Cuban
Missile Crisis and why he kept the
drafting of that speech secret within
the White House that he invited only a
handful of aides including galbart to
participate in or comment on the
drafting of the speech and didn't even
give a draft to his own State Department
of Defense Department until 48 hours
before he gave it knowing full well what
his aides and Staton and and defense
would think of the speech he was about
to give thank you I mean because I you
know as a man who's lived through the
trench warfare thank you thank you let
me just say that we'll be drawing to a
conclusion in a few minutes so I'd
invite the four people who are at the
microphones to be the last people asking
questions and then at the very end I'll
ask Robert and Richard to sum up yes sir
dan Asher from Cape Cod I have a
question with regard to gallopers
viewpoints on entitlements professor Raj
mentioned his concern about more more
medical care more not more health care
rather what is the viewpoint about the
future of the entitlement some of which
are mandated and cannot be dealt with by
Congress which continue to go up
rinses we just learned recently that I
don't know how many billions of dollars
will now be needed to support military
retirees and their spouses
this is something that's relatively new
and least in terms of public knowledge
what about the future of entitlements
most of which are important can we
afford them and what is what would he
what did he say and what would he say
about the escalating amounts Robert you
want to take that well I can I can I can
answer the second part of your question
that is what would he say Richard can
talk about what did he say
I think that Ken Galbraith would say and
will say and probably has said that the
problem of entitlements basically is a
problem not of Social Security Social
Security is not a problem I want to
assure you that it is not in crisis I
was a trustee of the Social Security
trust fund and I can tell you that if
you simply assume economic growth that
is normal an average level of economic
growth such as we've had over the past
hundred years and projected in the
future the Social Security trust fund at
worst has a little bit of a problem that
can easily be remedied without any
drastic fix and by the way diverting
trillions of dollars out of Social
Security into private accounts is not a
way to fix Social Security number one
number two the real problem with
entitlements is Medicare and to a lesser
extent Medicaid but that's all really
because we have a health care crisis in
this country and it's not Medicare's
fault and it's not medicaid's fault the
problem is we have the most expensive
per capita health care system of the
world and yet it is also one of the most
one of the least efficient we're the
only company we're the only I was going
to say company in the world we're the
only country in the world it feels like
a company sometimes we're the only
country in the world where our health
care system is designed to avoid sick
people and I mean that quite quite
literally health care providers spend
enormous amounts of money advertising
and marketing trying to avoid sick
people and finding groups of people that
are likely to have a lower risk of ill
health this makes no sense
administrative play it's very costly and
what we have to do unfortunately Social
Security is sort of preoccupying the
public and what we ought to be talking
about as we began to talk about in 1994
was how to fix a crazy incredibly
expensive out-of-control and very very
inefficient and inequitable health care
system but What did he say
professor rice does a terrific job of
channeling professor Galbraith what I
can tell you is that talking with him a
few months ago about this social
security crisis question
Galbraith predicted that the president
was going to fail in his attempts to
transform the Social Security system
because he said this administration and
this president think that what they're
doing is carrying out political warfare
against the Liberals in attacking Social
Security when it was simply that the
Liberals had the common sense to
recognize what the American people
wanted and then what this administration
blinded by its own ideology
misunderstood was that it was standing
against the ideas and interests and
desires of most of the American people
not against American liberalism and he
predicted in November that this would
not succeed yes ma'am listening to you
this afternoon mr. Parker I think that
professor Galbraith trusts in you to
represent his views adequately here this
afternoon was well placed indeed
I'm interested in knowing when you first
began thinking about writing a biography
of professor Galbraith and whether there
was any one thing in your background
that persuaded professor Galbraith that
you would be a worthy biographer or
whether the two of you just hit it off
and we're very compatible I decided that
I wanted to write this biography about
midway through the Reagan administration
they didn't actually get to work on it
until the early 1990s for a variety of
reasons but I did so because I was
looking at the current debate over
economics not only in the public but in
professional economics and found both
bankrupt quite frankly I mean in the
1980s there was a conservative push
within the profession for rational
expectations and monetarism and
supply-side and for monetarism and
supply-side in the realm of policy as
well and it was fairly obvious to me
that monetarism was not going to work as
a intellectual exercise nor as a
programmatic exercise which of course
turned out to be true there is no
country in the world today that actually
uses friedman i monetarism to guide its
monetary policy rational expectations
thought it had put a dagger in the heart
of Keynesianism in the late 1970s and
instead found itself thrusting the
dagger into its own heart in the early
1980s so much so that the prominent
figures who won a Nobel laureates for
their work and rational expectations no
longer no longer have anything to do
with the field and as a consequence
seeing this kind of dead end in both
contemporary theory and contemporary
politics I started to look around for
what seemed to me to have made sense in
the past and wanted to understand why it
had made sense in the past and to
actually wave whether elements of it
might make sense in the
future and I found John Kenneth
Galbraith as to how he and I hit it off
I certainly know that I hit it off with
him kitty can speak for whether he hit
it off with me I have no doubt that for
a man who can turn out twenty books in
eight years waiting eight years for me
to finish one must have tried his his
patience but he was an incredible he was
an incredible subject he never I could
say this quite honestly never attempted
to influence anything that I wrote he
said at the very beginning I don't want
to read the manuscript he said I would
like the opportunity to look at it in
galleys and in fact I gave it to him in
galleys last September and then spent as
my wife will tell you a miserable ten
days with my breath baited and my heart
stopped waiting to hear from him and of
course he then called and said we need
to talk and I went over and he said
there are some problems and he said
let's look here at page 17 and I opened
to page 17 and he said where you say I
grew up in Iona Station Canada and a
farm along a dirt road Richard it was a
gravel road 95 years of age yeah and we
did a dozen more of these and then to
her credit mrs. Galbraith weighed in and
explained to me that I've got the
sequence of cities which they had first
visited in 1938 in Europe partly out of
order that they had gone to Vienna
before Berlin not Berlin before Vienna
so it hit the the book has been vetted
you're welcome yes ma'am
I'm I'm glad you brought up the subject
of how professor Galbraith felt and
thought about the military budget as
opposed to the domestic budget for a
couple of reasons one is my name is
Susan Cher and I run an organization
called wand women's Action for New
Directions
and we do artist control and disarmament
we're doing a great job don't you think
and our mission is to reduce the
military budget and get money into human
and environmental needs and I spoke to
professor Galbraith a couple of years
ago at a party I told him what I did and
which he knew he's been involved with
our organization for 20 years and I
asked him for advice and he said good
luck and I think was because we were at
a party and he really wanted to have a
good time instead of giving me any
advice but I'm wondering if in this
climate if he said anything to you about
what we could be doing because we I know
he believed that putting money in the
Pentagon was not productive and was in
fact destructive and so he must have
given you his thoughts I I know that he
believed that America deserved a peace
ten dividend at the end of the Cold War
which it hasn't gotten and I know that
he's greatly concerned about the ways in
which this issue of global terrorism is
being shaped into a war against global
terrorism that requires a massive
increase in spending for the Pentagon he
believes that in fact Europe's
experience with terrorism in the 1970's
and early 1980s and a reliance on police
and intelligence activities rather than
a reliance on aircraft carriers
submarines missiles tanks and invasions
probably will bear greater fruit for us
and of course he believes that we have
missed an enormous the important
opportunity to drastically reduce the
number of nuclear weapons on the planet
today I haven't asked him about
specifics of Iran nuclear facilities or
North Korea
I was wondering if either one of you or
both could briefly summarize the
difference with Ken Galbraith and Milton
Friedman and why different dark I'm
sorry what was that light and dark if
you were a more religious audience I'd
say good and evil we're trying to keep
secular and profound mistake it's all in
short right bob says pretty much take
the advice noting Friedman I'm not sure
but Begley remember of something that
takes it didn't take much advice from
Milton Friedman and one index of built
in Friedman's relationship to the deep
recurrence of American life is that he
accused Nixon of being the most
socialist president in American history
could you also say who do you think of
the economic gurus of today both right
and left well I think Bob rice is one of
them and deserves to be
I think what makes Bob so important to
our generation is that he combines can
sense of analytic ability with the
political courage and vision that can
also had there are other economists Paul
Krugman Joe Stiglitz Jeffrey Sachs and
more recent work that he's been doing
and the so-called Millennium Development
Goals all of whom are important and yet
in some funny way the role that ken
Galbraith played as a public
intellectual in the 1950s is a role
being played in a peculiar way by Bono
today of the rock group you to the I
don't know whether this is the way in
which serious culture has been denatured
by television or not but it seems to me
that there is a generation that looks to
rock stars for moral and political
guidance whether we like it or not and
so in that sense perhaps if we could
just get Bob and Bono playing together
on stage as a benefit for liberal values
you might have the combination I'd note
you on drums I'd know I'd note Richard
that the highest compliment that seemed
to be able to be paid to His Holiness
John Paul the second last week was that
he was he had achieved the status of a
rock star Robert do you have a last
remark there's still so much to be said
and I don't know how many of you saw the
Gallup poll last week and which it was
revealed that about 18% of Americans now
believe that the earth will end in their
lifetimes and approximately 17% of
Americans consider themselves to be
liberals so more people believe the
earth will end in their lifetimes
then describe themselves being liberal
the word liberal has obviously gone out
of fashion
ken Galbraith is and and was perhaps the
leading liberal in America and as you
look to the future I think we need at
least can to be with us for another
twenty or thirty years given how things
are going but I want to especially thank
John Shattuck and Debby left of the
Kennedy Library for putting this on and
also Jim you for hosting but most
especially my dear friend Richard Parker
for dedicating the last eight or nine
years of his life to a book that is so
important and a fitting memorial to one
who continues to live with us who had
and still towers and certainly towered
of the 20th century John Kenneth
Galbraith thank you Mark
last word it falls to me to thank to add
my thanks to Roberts to the Kennedy
Library John Shattuck who himself a
public intellectual diplomat embodies
the legacy of this place we all know how
pleased professor Galbraith is by this
gathering and we can assume how precious
it is to him that it is taking place at
the Kennedy Library mrs. Galbraith would
you carry away from this place the love
and profound respect from everyone
gathered here please tell Kim how very
much we thank him and how we wish him
well and continue to depend on him to be
with us and to be the ever unmatchable
unsurpassable John Kenneth Galbraith
thank you ladies